The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from 100's
of MIT courses, visit MIT
OpenCourseWare at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Why don't we
go ahead and get started.
What we're going
to be talking about
today, is what happens after
that photon gets absorbed.
So we spent a great deal of
time in our last lecture talking
about light absorption, the
interaction between light
and the semiconductor.
Now we're going to
talk about what happens
once that light is absorbed.
So we're in the
fundamental section.
We're right here.
Later on, we'll get
into the technologies
and the cross cutting themes.
As we go through
the fundamentals,
I'm going to attempt to
relate those fundamentals
to real solar cell technology.
So you're not left
kind of floating,
wondering why it is that
we're studying this stuff,
but you're really
seeing the connection
to solar cell devices.
So first if we remind everyone
of the broader picture
that the conversion efficiency,
the ultimate performance
of the device, is defined as the
output energy versus the input
energy.
And for most solar
cells, this breaks down
into the inputs and the outputs.
The input being
the solar spectrum
and the output being the
collection of charge.
And there are multiple processes
that occur here in the middle.
Light absorption, we
talked about last time.
We're going to be talking about
charge excitation in charge
transport today, mostly
charge excitation.
So we're right here.
We're going to be
marching steadily
down toward the right over
the next few lectures.
And let me remind
you, everybody,
that the efficiency
of the device
is the product of each
individual efficiency
of each different step.
So if anything is
going wrong here,
it will be limiting
device performance.
And the image you should
definitely have in your mind
is of that bucket, with
each plank representing
a different component
of the device, perhaps
a different physical
process or perhaps
a different physical component
of the device itself.
And whatever is the
poorest, is going
to be limiting
overall performance.
Your efficiency is going to be
flowing out from that low plank
and you will have a
low efficiency device.
So the art of making a
high efficiency solar cell
is really understanding
everything
that goes into the
physical processes,
but also the devices.
And that's why we break
it down like this.
We have the physical
processes, and finally we
get into some of the
devices in the architectures
of manufacturing methods.
So learning objectives today.
Oops.
That was a little bit of a typo.
It's not the solar resource.
We're talking about
charge excitation today.
We will be talking phenomena
logically how this thing called
a band gap forms.
It's a very important
physical concept.
We'll lead off the
lecture with it,
and then very quickly
go into applications
that you see why it's
important, returning back
to the fundamentals,
how it actually forms,
going back and
forth until we have
a pretty solid understanding.
From the background surveys,
I understand that about 50%
of you understand
what a band gap is.
So 50% of you may be a little
bored, or a little entertained,
at my hand wave explanations
during the first part of class.
I encourage you to
think about the band gap
from the perspective of
the solar cell device,
because this is probably not
something you've done before.
You've probably
understood band gap
from the perspective of
a semiconductor device as
packaged in the dark, perhaps
in a little gadget like this.
But not something
that's exposed to light
with the addition of
a generation current.
Or at least not in detail.
So I welcome you
to think about that
as we go through
the explanations
in the beginning of class.
Then we'll describe how optical
absorption in semiconductors
represents the transitions
of charge in an energy band
diagram.
In other words, if
we imagine a given
space of the
semiconductor divisive,
say a surrounding
of a given atom,
and we imagine that different
orbitals, different electron
orbitals will have different
energies associated with them.
We are going to be talking
about how light gets absorbed
in transitions electrons
between those different energy
orbitals.
That's important
because then we'll
be able to calculate
the fraction of photons
lost, not absorbed, by a
given semiconductor material.
We'll be able to calculate
the fraction of incident
solar energy that is lost
as well, due to a phenomenon
called thermalization.
And finally, we're
going to be able to plot
efficiency versus
band gap, and denote
specific materials on it.
In other words, we are going to
be doing our first higher level
efficiency calculations
for a solar cell device
by the end of today's lecture.
And the idea is to expose a
little bit on the technology
side as well, so that you have
an appreciation for what's
up and coming in the field,
what are some of the ways
to enhance the performance
of social devices.
So band gap.
Very, very basic description.
If you've never been
exposed to band gaps before,
the reason it's important
is because the band gap
is going to define
what color, what
portion of the solar
spectrum that material
absorbs light most efficiently.
How a band gap forms is related
to the atomic structure.
Think of bonds as essentially
why stuff is tough.
If the mechanical
engineers in the room,
if you remember
linear elasticity,
those bonds are
what are essentially
forming those springs
between the atoms that
are keeping them, the
material, from flying apart.
There is also a very
interesting property here,
that if you have
a bound electron,
it's usually not moving
very far that atom.
It's usually in a very
localized electronic state
close to that atom.
So if you were to apply a
resistance meter, an Ohm meter,
to your device to measure
the resistance across it,
and you had just
bound electrons,
you would measure a very,
very low current passing
through that material.
Because there would be very few
free charge carriers to move
in that applied field, when
you apply the two probes
and there's a little
battery in here that applies
a field across the
material, you wouldn't
be able to measure
much current flow,
because there wouldn't be too
many free electrons to carry
that current.
So the bound
electrons essentially
enhance the strength
of the material.
But it doesn't help us from a
semiconductor point of view.
What we need are
excited electrons.
And excited electrons are
why materials conduct.
So let's imagine we have a bond.
For example, in
this material right
here, these gray lines
are really two electrons
that are covalently bonded.
Essentially two
electrons-- one electron
from each little black circle
representing a carbon atom.
And each electron associated
with that carbon atom
is shared with the other,
in a covalent bond.
And for the chemists
in the room, more
precisely, you have
sp3 hybridized orbitals
in this diamond cubic
crystal structure.
For everyone else, these
are shared electrons
in a covalent bonding
configuration.
Now if light comes in
with enough energy,
it can excite an electron
from that covalently bonded
state into an excited state,
where it can then roam freely
throughout the lattice.
And that's the nature
of charge excitations.
So the big question
that we have to ask
ourselves is, what
color of light
will this material
absorb most effectively?
Will those electrons
in the covalent bonds
absorb light and be
excited into a state
where they can roam freely
around the material,
and ultimately
conduct electricity?
OK.
So the answer to that
question is not simple.
Understanding how
a band gap forms
can be an entire semester
of quantum physics.
But what we're going to do is
do it in a three step approach.
Simple, very, very
simple explanations
that hopefully
everyone will get.
The next most
simple explanation,
which hopefully 80% of
you will get, and then
perhaps a more detailed
explanation that only a few
of you will get.
But the idea is
to really progress
in levels of explanation.
So let me go back one step.
Yeah.
The band gap energy can
be most simply understood
as a finite amount
of energy needed
to excite a highly
localized electron
into a de-localized excited
state in the semiconductor
where it can move
around the crystal.
OK.
So this is the description
of the band gap,
how a band gap forms that
you'll see in many chemistry
textbooks.
And I like it, because it's
something that you can really
grasp and understand.
We have to start with
the simple premise
that electrons are a type of
particle called a fermion.
What is a fermion?
Let's refresh our
basic physics here.
What means a fermion?
Spin one half.
And it also means-- can two
fermions occupy the same state?
No, they can't.
Bosons can.
But fermions cannot.
And so what happens when you
put two fermions together
in a system?
And say we have
discretized quantum states.
We begin filling up from
the bottom up, right?
Typically.
So the lowest energy
states get occupied first.
You have, for example, spin up,
spin down in your s orbital.
And then they begin populating
the next electron orbital.
Once that's filled, you go to
the next one, and the next one.
So if we have one
atom in isolation,
the easiest example
is that hydrogen atom,
for those who took quantum
mechanics, who actually
calculated the energy
of the bound electron
there in the ground state of the
hydrogen atom, around 13.6 eV.
So imagine now you take a
silicon atom, or carbon atom,
or something else,
a little bit bigger,
more electrons in its structure.
So you have the core,
the 1s orbital filled.
And then you start
progressing outward.
2s2p and so forth.
And so you begin
filling up the orbitals.
Let's see atomic separation.
So imagine that we have our
atoms infinitely separated.
So we have just one
atom in the middle
of an infinite lonely space.
One atom.
And we would have discrete
energy levels corresponding
to the different orbitals,
the different orbitals
around the nucleus.
Now imagine the atom
is no longer lonely.
It now has a partner.
And you bring those two atoms
closer and closer and closer
together.
That's this d getting
closer and closer together.
What happens?
Well, electrons are fermions.
They don't like occupying
the same electronic state.
So first, the first
shell that's going
to quote, unquote
see each other,
the first electron shell
that will interact is what?
Is it the outermost,
or the innermost?
Outermost.
Right?
Because they're the
closest together.
So you're moving the two
atoms closer together,
that outermost shell will
begin to quote, unquote see
the other atom.
And those electrons will say,
hey, you're occupying my state.
And what will happen is
they'll begin splitting,
in energy level, and that's
what you see right here.
What this is representing is not
just two atoms coming together,
but a multitude of
atoms coming together.
And we have to really
imagine, for example,
and in most matter, we have
something in the order of 10
to the 22, 10 to the 23
atoms per cubic centimeter.
So atoms per cubic centimeter.
Fun math, just total aside.
If anybody talks about
teletransporttion,
think about the number
of atoms in your body.
And assign an
xyz-coordinate to them,
and then calculate the
amount of data in terabytes.
And then calculate
our Ethernet speeds,
and try to figure out how
long it would take to transmit
that data to the other side.
Anyway.
So this is to give
you an impression
of the density of atoms
within the cubic centimeter.
So you have a lot of
atoms coming together,
even though the electron
wave function can
be highly localized, they still
interfere with each other.
There's still enough
atoms coming together
that you have this interference.
And it's not just two electron
states, but many of them
that are splitting, that
are forming a band of states
because no two electrons
can occupy the same energy
level as these atoms
are coming together.
Now, as they become closer
and closer and closer,
it's not only that outer
shell that begins interacting.
It's the next most outer shell.
This one, here, that
begins interacting.
And finally another
shell, and another shell.
And so at some
equilibrium distance,
the equilibrium
distance here defined
as the attractive
potential between atoms.
There's an energy gain
by forming that bond.
And the repulsive
force of the nuclei,
their large concentration
of positive charge
in the nucleus, that if
you tried pushing them too
close together, they'll repel.
This balance of forces,
the attractive potential
due to that bond formation, the
repulsive force to the nucleic,
results in an equilibrium
bond distance,
d, shown here as
this dotted line.
And at that equilibrium bond
distance, some of the orbitals
will be forming bands and
other orbitals will still
be discrete, namely
the core orbitals
will still be discrete.
The outermost orbitals
here will be forming bands.
Now an interesting thing
happens when it just so occurs,
and say, for example,
in the system right
here, this shell is filled.
This shell is filled.
This shell is completely filled.
And let's imagine that
this orbital exists,
but it's unpopulated.
You ran out of electrons.
And you started
filling in the orbitals
of this atom over here.
You had enough for this orbital,
that orbital, that orbital,
but then you ran
out of electrons.
You didn't have anything more.
And this band of
states was empty.
So the band of allowed
states exists up there,
but it's empty.
And this band right here
exists, and it's filled.
These core states exist,
and they're filled as well.
So the action is really
happening right here.
If light comes in, if
visible light comes in,
it's probably going to excite an
electron from this filled band
right here to somewhere in
this unoccupied band up there.
And this gap, right here,
is an interesting thing.
There is no stable
electron orbital.
If you were somehow to take
an electron with that given
energy, this energy
here, from the vacuum
and stick it inside
of the system here,
it would quickly decay
into a stable orbital.
So this is a prohibited
band of states.
There is no stable
orbital for that electron
to exist at that energy.
And hence we call it a band gap.
The reason band gaps
are interesting,
is because different materials
have different, or can
have different, size band gaps.
Some don't have a
band gap at all.
Most of those that don't
have a band gap, because you
have a band of states like
this one that's partially full.
Let's imagine we
have three electrons
in this band right here.
One, two, three.
And then we have these other
four empty states about it.
In fact, you have a
partially filled band.
And let's imagine,
instead of just having
seven states within that band,
we had a multitude of states
within that band.
Almost too many to count.
And now, with even the
slightest of energy,
we could excite an
electron from this state
into that state
plus little delta.
That would be a metal.
Now if we had a
really big band gap,
we wouldn't be able
to absorb much light.
Because you'd need a
large amount of energy
to excite across that band gap.
And that would be an
example of, say, glass.
Where light would come in.
Most of our visible spectrum
makes it through the glass,
and that's why we see
through the other side.
And diamonds as well.
OK.
So let's review.
An atom in isolation has
discrete electron energy
levels.
And on this diagram
right here, it's
represented with this d,
the atomic separation being
way out here.
We have discrete energy levels.
And that we can remember from
our basic physics, especially
the hydrogen atom.
And as atoms move
closer together,
as in a crystal, where you
have a regularly repeating
arrangements of atoms, the
electron wave functions begin
overlapping, and since
electrons are fermions,
meaning that the two electrons
can't occupy the same state,
you have a splitting of those
energy levels forming bands.
And you can see the splitting
as you move from right to left,
as you move from
further to closer,
on these diagrams right here.
First starting with the
outermost states, the most
valence of electron orbitals,
and then slowly moving
into the core states as well.
And the gap between
bands denoting an energy
range in which no stable orbital
exists is called a band gap.
Sometimes you'll see it
all written as one word.
Sometimes there will be a space
between the band and the gap.
Any questions so far?
OK.
So now this explanation should
be relatively straightforward.
What I want you to
log into your ram,
because we're going into some
more detailed explanations,
and I want to set a
marker, a flag, so we
can come back here afterward.
And even if you're lost with
the subsequent explanations,
you still get this one.
Right?
So remember these three points.
If you make a note of them
in your notes, and we're
going to move on to a few
more explanations here.
OK, so another way of looking
at this which really builds
on the folks who have had a more
advanced physics backgrounds,
is that the wave function
of an electron, inside
of a crystal-- if
you recall the wave
function of an electron in
free space, we have what
is called the plane wave
equation for the electron.
It's this regular repeating,
nice stable function.
Now if we introduce that
electron into a crystal,
it's almost like an infinitely
repeating system of atoms.
And so you could
envision that you
could describe the wave
function of that electron
as a combination
of a plane wave,
but perturbed by that
locally repeating potential
from the atomic nuclei.
And let me be more
specific about
regular repeating potential.
What I mean is that you have
a series of nuclei here,
and if you imagine the electron
potential around these nuclei,
there is a propensity
for the election
to be bound by the atom.
And so as it's moving along,
instead of just a free plane
wave, now it's almost like
driving along a bumpy road,
bump, bump, bump.
And so the wave
function of the electron
can be described as this
combination or product
of the wave function
of a plane wave,
envelope function describing
the electron localization.
So you have this
localized function here
and the delocalized function
describing the plane wave
behavior of the electron as
it moves through space inside
of the crystal.
Now what we have as an
easy way to describe this
mathematically, is we
make an approximation.
Instead of describing
this potential in detail,
the easiest way to do this is
to describe this square well
potential.
We have a so-called
Kronig-Penney idealization
of the repeating
Coulombic potential.
It's easier to
solve numerically.
And then essentially
what we do is
we solve Schrodinger's equation
for two possible solutions.
One is for the electron
wave function centered
on the atoms themselves.
So that would be
the bound state.
And the other is we solve the
equation for electron function
centered between the atoms.
So essentially in the
unbound state, right here.
Which do you think will have
the higher energy level?
In between the states, right?
Because if the electron wave
function is centered over here,
it's further away from the
positive charge of the nuclei.
You need more energy to
put it into that position.
It's an unbound state, but it's
also at a higher excited energy
level.
Whereas if it's bound
around the atoms themselves,
you would have a
lower energy state.
In this delta of energy
levels between the bound
and the excited states
represents the band gap
of the semiconductor in
this simple approximation
right here.
Now you can take that one step
further and say, well, gee,
if I could solve
that in one dimension
in a very simple
case, why don't I
put a three dimensional
structure in place,
such as a real crystal, and then
solve the Schrodinger equation?
And sure you can do that.
You can definitely do that.
It becomes much more complicated
solution numerically,
but the general principle
stays roughly the same.
You can add several more
tricks, and bells, and whistles.
And of course, I would
probably emphasize
that the solution
could either be
done numerically or you
could use the symmetry
relations of the
crystal to develop
a very simple expression
of the crystal,
minimizing the
redundant directions
inside of the crystal,
collapsing it down
into the bare essential
to describe that crystal
structure.
And we would have some uniform
energy space that looks,
for example, represented by
this yellowish surface, where
you'd have an isopotential
inside of your crystal
structure.
So these are different ways of
looking at the band gap inside
of a semiconductor crystal.
If you're really interested,
and for the advance reading,
I would definitely
suggest this book called,
Fundamentals of Semiconductors,
by Professor Peter Yu,
now retired at UC Berkeley.
Very nice explanation.
Uses an elegant
application of group theory
to derive the band structure
of a semiconductor in detail.
So let's hop back to this one,
real quick-- actually, yeah?
AUDIENCE: I'm just
curious if you
could tell us the name
of the equation that
was at the top of--
PROFESSOR: Sure.
Absolutely.
So what we're describing here
is essentially the e to the ikx,
or e to the ikr,
essentially describing
that periodic potential.
And then in essentially
an envelope function.
So, yeah, that would
be the wave function
that would be introduced into
the Schrodinger equation.
So let's go back to
here really quickly,
because I don't want to
get us lost in the weeds.
I want us to focus on the
main concepts at hand.
Let's, from an engineering
point of view--
given this formation of bands
inside of real materials,
since the atoms are coming
together and forming crystals,
we can envision a few
different scenarios.
Let's focus on the
this band here,
and that band here, and the
space in between them, the band
gap.
And let's assume that
we have this band
here either completely
filled or partially filled,
and talk about what
happens in three
different extreme scenarios.
In one case, when we have
the band partially filled,
we have what is
known as a metal.
And the reason this
case is interesting
is because a very
small amount of energy
is all that it would take
to excite an electron
and make it to move
around the crystal.
As a matter of fact,
a metal has what's
called electron c, that
serves to conduct electricity
at room temperature and
even at very, very, very
low temperatures.
Semiconductor, on
the other hand.
Now semiconductor has
a finite band gap,
and we'll get to
this in a minute.
Let's start with the
insulator, because that's
a more easy to understand case.
If the band gap is
very, very, very big,
then a large amount
of energy is required
to excite an electron
into an unbound state,
so it can move freely
across the crystal.
And as a result,
you're not going
to have a very large population
of electrons up here.
The photo excited
carrier population,
meaning the population of
charge carriers, electrons,
that are excited into here
from light, is very small.
And the thermally excited
carrier concentration,
just some background
thermal energy,
kt, Boltzmann's constant
times temperature,
that energy is also going to be
insufficient to drive electrons
across this band gap.
And as a result, you will have
a very, very small population
of carriers up here.
And this will be an
insulator, because you
will have very few charges
to transport current.
If you apply a potential
across an insulator,
you will not have very
much current flow.
And that's the principle
of insulating materials
around wires.
Actually this is in
the semiconductor.
This is a polymer.
But if we had, for
example, glass or diamond,
that would serve as a
nice insulator as well.
Now a semiconductor material
is somewhere between a metal
and an insulator here.
And that the band
gap is now shrinking.
The band gap is small enough
to interact with lights,
typically.
For example, this
little piece of silicon,
which I'll show in
detail in a minute,
towards the end of class.
It doesn't look clear,
like glass does.
It looks opaque.
And that's because
it's absorbing photons
in the visible spectrum.
But it's letting some of the
infrared photons go through it.
Some of the very
low energy photons
can go through the material,
because those photons
have insufficient energy
to excite carriers
across that band gap.
So we have a semiconductor
material, defined here
as having a band gap.
That band gap defines the
energy of the light that
is most efficiently absorbed.
And any photon with energy
in excess of the band gap
can also be absorbed
by that semiconductor.
Any questions so far?
AUDIENCE: Are there
any natural materials
where the spacing
of the bands is such
that three bands are active,
or is it always just two bands
which are active?
PROFESSOR: Interesting.
So the question is, are
there more bands above here
that you could excite into?
Absolutely.
So as you can envision,
back here for instance,
you could continue drawing
more and more and more bands.
They're unoccupied,
but they exist.
And as the atoms come
closer and closer together,
those begin interacting as well.
And so in a few
lectures we'll look
at a band diagram
of a semiconductor,
and we'll see all
the occupied bands,
and all the unoccupied bands.
And you can excite
into any one of them
if you have the right
excitation condition.
Let's put it that way.
Any other questions?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I'm having
trouble seeing the chemist's
description along
with the physicist's
description along with
this slide all together.
How does, once it's in
the crystal structure
and it's in its
lattices and everything,
how does that look
in this picture?
Where is that in this picture.
PROFESSOR: Sure.
So this one here, let
me describe the axes,
because that might make things
a little easier to understand.
In the vertical axis
here, we have energy.
And that's the same axis as
we have right here, energy.
In this axis right here, we
had inter atomic separation.
So this was meant
to demonstrate what
happens when we bring atoms
closer and close together.
In this description
right here, this
is an unlabeled axis that could
be x real space, for instance.
Why do we plot an
x in the x-axis?
Why do we plot real space?
Well sometimes, when we talk
about solar cell devices,
we're talking about
bringing charge
from deep within the device
to the front surface where
the contact is.
And so we want to talk about the
flow of charge in real space.
So that's oftentimes why
you see in these band
diagrams for solar
cells, you'll see
e versus x, versus real space.
Now let me show you what these
two levels here represent.
This is the top
of the filled band
and the bottom of
the empty band.
And those correspond over here.
I'm going to use the
mouse now, because I'm
going to be stretching.
Let's imagine that this
level on down was filled.
And that this level
up here is empty.
So if I may, these
are all filled.
All filled.
And this one here is empty.
Gonna take a little bit.
Here we go.
All right.
So now this band is going to
be filled, because we're really
looking at the equilibrium inter
atomic separation in a crystal.
We're looking right here this d.
That's the spacing right
now of those atoms inside
of that piece of
semiconductor material, inside
of that silicon.
So what we care about
is this right here.
And this would be the
top of the filled band,
and this would be the
bottom of the empty band,
corresponding to the top of
the filled band right here
and the bottom of the
empty band right there.
So that's how it
all fits together.
This diagram here can
get kind of confusing
when you're looking in
the abscissa, essentially
the x-axis.
Because you're thinking
in terms of real space.
Well, it is real space, but
you're bringing atoms together.
So it's really meant to
be a phenomenological tool
to describe how band gaps form.
This diagram over
here, we're now
starting to get into the
engineering diagrams that
can help explain how
solar cells work.
And from here on out, we'll
be abandoning that chemists
diagram and simply
using this one
because we assume that we're not
applying a significant strain
to our semiconductor
material to get
significant deviations here.
We'd have to apply strains
of several percent,
and probably result in
fracture of our semiconductor
before we ended up changing
that inter-atomic distance.
We could also heat it up.
It's another way of introducing
strain, thermal strain,
but not mechanical.
OK.
So did that help
answer the question?
OK.
So the second
point here, we want
to first off describe
phenomenological band gap
and understand how that works.
Secondly, we want to
describe optical transitions
in the semiconductor and
understand how charge carriers,
in other words, how electrons
on an energy band diagram
are moving around.
Why do we call electrons
charge carriers once again?
Remind me, from
this diagram here.
Exactly.
It's brilliant.
I just want to make sure
that those two things are
synonymous in people's
minds, that we're not getting
caught up on the language.
Thank you.
So again, charge
carriers, electrons,
being free electrons, unbound
electrons, not any electron,
not the ones down here, but
the ones that are excited.
OK, so let's go back to lecture
number two, I think it was,
where we talk about
the duality of light.
It's a wave and a particle.
Well it can be thought of, can
be described mathematically
as waves and particles.
We've, in last
lecture, when we talked
about lights and the interaction
with lights with materials,
we referred to light
mostly as a wave.
This was very easy for us
to describe interference.
It made it convenient to
do the homework problems,
especially for the graduate
students, the last problem.
That was a lot of fun
But now we will be
talking about life
in terms of discrete
quanta of energy,
because one photon
is going to be
absorbed by an electron,
an excited electron,
into another state.
So now we think of the photon
as having a certain energy,
defined by the
wavelength of light,
and that energy is going to be
given to the electron, which
will then be excited inside
of our semiconductor crystal.
So what happens?
Well we have our sun.
Here we have our
semiconductor crystal.
Again, I'm representing
it in terms of e versus x.
I'm saying that these
states here are filled.
And these states here
are mostly empty.
And these are mostly filled.
Mostly empty.
And this is my band
gap right here.
I'm plotting e in the
ordinate and x real space
in the abscissa.
And again, x because,
ultimately, we'll
be looking at the cross
section of the solar cell
in x, in describing how charge
gets extracted from the device.
So that's why we're going
to be using x on this axis.
Now we have sunlight here,
outside of our device.
And it's going to
be shining light
onto the semiconductor crystal.
So what happens?
Well, we know
intuitively that charge
should be excited
from a bound states
to an unbound state, where it
can move around the material.
But not all light
serves this function.
If we have a photon that has
an energy above the band gap
energy, so e photon, meaning the
energy of the incident photon
is greater than e gap, the
energy band gap, then we'll
have an excitation of charge.
We'll have an electron taken
from somewhere here, brought up
to a higher excited
states, and it
might come to settle down at the
bottom of that band of states
that is allowed.
A settling, if you will.
But if our photon energy
is less than our band gap,
we won't have this
process occur.
Instead we'll have the light
going straight through it.
And this is
brilliant, because you
can begin to understand
the behavior of many solids
in this way.
Let's take a glass,
for instance.
How many you have noticed
that you never get sunburned
when the windows are up?
But you get sunburned when you
forget to put the windows up,
when you're driving around
and your arm's sticking out,
you get that nice truckers tan.
That's because the ultraviolet
photons have enough energy
in glass to excite electrons
across the band gap.
So the ultraviolet photons
gets absorbed by the glass,
but the visible photons instead
are coming straight through,
much like this.
Now glass has a
very large band gap.
Now silicon, much
smaller band gap.
And in that case, in
the case of silicon,
even the visible gets blocked.
So silicon would make
a really crummy window.
But it makes a really
great infrared window.
So if you're detecting
infrared light,
and want to block
out all the visible,
you might consider sticking
up a filter made of silicon.
And that's regularly
done in laboratories.
So you can begin
to understand how
light interacts with
matter, with solids,
using this energy band diagram.
And ultimately how these
optical absorption spectra
come into being.
So we studied these
optical absorption spectra
in our last class.
We just took them as a given.
We didn't question
where they came from.
Now we're going to be focusing
on this so-called turn
on energy, or turn
on wave length.
Remember wavelength and
energy are interchangeable.
I've written down below here
the energy corresponding
to a given wavelength,
around 2000 nanometers.
We have an energy
of around 0.62 eV.
At around 200 nanometers,
we have an energy of 6.2 eV.
Since one is the reciprocal
of the other, related by hc,
it's only natural
that if we change one
by an order of magnitude,
we're changing the other
by an order of magnitude
in the opposite direction.
So we're wrapping our minds
around this interchangeability
of wavelength and energy.
That's important,
because we'll be
referring to them very
naturally as a photon
either having a certain
wavelength or a certain energy.
You notice that there are
certain turn on energies.
So energy is increasing
in that direction there.
So as we go from
infrared to ultraviolet,
the energy of the incoming
light is increasing.
And if the energy is too low,
the semiconductor crystal
just won't absorb.
The absorptance is 0,
or very, very small.
It doesn't even appear
on the log plot here.
And as we begin
increasing the energy,
suddenly there's like a turn on.
The semiconductor begins
to absorb that light,
and you begin to have this
process occur right here.
You begin to go from
that red light that
went straight
through the material,
to this blue light example here
where we have absorption event.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: This is probably a
minor question, but where does
the energy go-- that it's
released when your electron
settles back down?
PROFESSOR: We're
going to get to that.
We're taking it step by step.
That's a really good question.
You're one step ahead of me.
We're going to be describing the
actual shape and character up
here, because this
is really equally
important for the functioning
of a solar cell device,
over the next few lectures.
But that gets
really complicated.
So for now, we're going to just
focus on this turn on energy.
And we're going to make
some assumptions from here
on out that the
semiconductor doesn't absorb,
and all of a sudden it absorbs,
and the absorption goes high.
It begins absorbing
all of our light,
for purposes of our
homework assignments.
So again, just to put this
all into one big picture,
so far we have the case out
here where very little light is
absorbed by our semiconductor.
We have the case of glass, light
coming straight through it,
visible light rather.
Because the incident
photon energy
is less than the band gap,
there is insufficient energy
to excite into the
conduction band.
Now as we transition
from a photon energy
less than the band gap to photon
energy larger than the band
gap, we can begin exciting
electrons or charges
across the band
gap, and that's why
we get absorption inside of
our semiconductor materials.
Any questions so far?
OK.
Good.
Everybody's still with me.
We're going to now calculate
the fraction of photons lost,
not absorbed by a
semiconductor material
with a given band gap,
thickness, and reflectivity.
And this gets to Ashley's
question right here.
So again, we ran through a
thickness estimate in class
the last time.
And we assumed for
a semiconductor,
I think it was around
800 nanometers.
For gallium,
arsenide, and silicon.
Or maybe it was a little
less, somewhere around 550.
What was the thickness necessary
to absorb say 90% of the light
at a given wavelength?
And we, in the
back of our minds,
have the solar spectrum
here as a reference point
to begin visualizing
the number of photons
that occur within each of these
delta wavelengths down here.
Essentially what portions of
the spectrum really matter?
Obviously you're not going
to optimize your solar cell
to absorb light way out here,
because there's really not
too much of the solar
spectrum way out there.
You're probably
going to optimize it
somewhere around the peak
of the solar spectrum,
somewhere near there.
So we walked through
that in the last class.
I want to have that in your
ram as we move forward.
We want to calculate
the fraction
of incident solar energy
lost to this thing called
thermalization that Ashley
was mentioning before.
We have, in this simplified
diagram right here,
an electron popping up
to a higher energy level
and then settling down to the
bottom of this conduction band,
we call it, this band
of states that's empty
right here, or largely empty.
And this settling
down to the bottom
of what is this mostly
empty band of states
is a process called
thermalization.
And it occurs,
well, because there
are a series of states the
electron can very easily move
between them by emitting
phonons, or lattice vibrations,
or heat.
And very quickly that
electron will settle down
into what is called or referred
to as the conduction band
minimum, the minimum energy
level within the conduction
band.
And this little arrow
shown in red right
here has a component in the
y-axis, in e space here,
which is a finite energy.
We can quantify that.
That thermalization
loss right there
is the difference
between this energy level
and that energy level
of the electron.
And so that's the
thermalization loss.
That is another type of loss
of a semiconductor crystal.
So we've discussed two so far.
We've discussed
non-absorption of light.
There are certain long
wavelengths, low energy light,
that go straight to our
material and doesn't
get absorbed, because the photon
energy is less than the band
gap.
And the second
major loss mechanism
is when we have too much
energy of the incoming photon,
we have an excitation
of a bound electron
into a very highly
unbound state,
and then a quick loss of that
excess energy due to a process
called thermalization.
Any questions so far?
AUDIENCE: You said that
the thermalization can
result in heat being
released or phonons--
PROFESSOR: Mh-hmm.
Yeah.
So not the prime energy that
we extract from the solar cell
of electricity.
In principle, if you could
develop some clever way
of extracting heat,
perhaps by slapping
on a thermoelectric device in
the back of your solar cell,
then you could extract
that energy as well.
So there's a potential
to recover that heat.
It's not total loss, but from
a mechanical engineering point
of view, if you think about
the thermodynamic efficiency
of a Carnot engine, where
your t high is this,
and your t low is your
ambient temperature,
that delta really
doesn't look that good.
Yeah.
It's really tiny.
So you have to think of a
more clever mechanism, perhaps
through a thermoelectric
device, or some other mechanism
to extract that extra
thermalization loss.
I wanted to-- so
what we're doing
is we're taking the
simplest picture,
and then adding
layers of complexity.
And you'll hear me
stumbling over my language,
as I sanitize it in
my head, to remove
all of the complex techno lingo,
and reduce it to its essence.
And so right now I'm
going to add one more
layer of complexity,
and ultimately
build up to the point where
I can feel conversant again.
We have incoming light,
not exciting the electron
all the way up to there from
the top of the valence band,
but typically somewhere
within the valence band.
Not really at the valence band
maximum or the maximum energy
level within the valence band,
these being the filled states.
So this is a more
realistic representation
of charge excitation.
We have an electron
being excited up.
And this little h plus that's
right here, who did the reading
and know what that
h plus represents?
A hole.
So what is a hole?
It's just what it sounds like.
It's the absence of an electron.
There used to be electron here.
Now it's up there.
It left behind a hole.
An easy way to
think about a hole
is if you're in a big traffic
jam, bumper to bumper,
something bad happened up ahead,
and backed up the traffic.
Now imagine just removing
one car from that highway.
You've created a hole.
So the car that used to be
behind that hole moves forward.
And the car that used to be
behind that one moves forward.
So three cars moved forward.
And the hole moved
backward three places.
Right.
So you can either describe
the dynamics of the system
as n number of
cars moving forward
or one hole moving
backwards n places.
It's much simpler from an
accountability point of view
to be talking about one
quasi particle, a hole,
rather than talking about
n cars moving forward,
n electrons moving.
So when we talk about
this hole right here,
thermalization is going
to drive this electron
to the lowest energy level
within the conduction band.
And it's also going to drive
the electrons above the hole,
essentially to fall
down into the hole.
In other words, the
hole is going to move up
to the top of the valence band.
Yes.
Question.
AUDIENCE: Why isn't the
hole originally created
at the top of the band?
PROFESSOR: Well,
it really depends
on what's called the matrix
element of the absorption
process.
In other words, what electrons
have the largest capture
cross section for
that incident photon.
And it is a probability
distribution function.
So you will get some
electrons further down
from the top of the valence
band absorbing light, as well
as some of the
electrons right there
at the tippy top of the
valence band absorbing light.
So I'm representing, say
for example, a typical case,
where you have an
electron that's
not right at the top of the
valence band, and certainly not
deep in the core level,
but nearish enough
to the top of the valence band
absorbing that light being
excited across.
So in reality,
this is meant to be
an arbitrary scale here,
but more representative
of a whole process.
And to think about this in
a more realistic sense, what
you would do is you think,
OK, I've this incoming photon,
and there's a certain
probability distribution
function that represents the
probability of absorptance
by different electrons
in my system.
Which one is going to absorb
the light, let's roll the dice.
Do a Monte Carlo.
OK.
That one absorbed it this time.
That one got excited up.
OK.
Another photon with
identical energy coming in.
Which electron absorbs it?
That one.
So that's the way I would
say it really works.
This is a simple representation
on the lecture slide.
So we have the hole going up,
and the electron going down.
Both particles are relaxing.
Right.
So the electron is moving
to its lowest energy state
and the hole is also moving
to its lowest energy state.
So if you want to think about
the electron as a bowling ball,
and the hole as a balloon,
you're welcome to.
Whatever mechanism helps you
think through this process,
use that as a crutch right
now as we move forward.
Always remember
that in the system,
these are electrons essentially
moving down, and filling up
that hole, and
the hole is moving
in the opposite direction, much
like the vacancy in a traffic
jam.
So again, thermalization
losses can
be described by both electrons
and holes in our system,
by both the rattling around of
an electron in the conduction
band and the
settling of electrons
here in the valence
band as well,
or the rising of that hole
toward the valence band
maximum and the settling of that
electron toward the conduction
band minimum.
So a natural question is,
how fast is this process?
Can it be reversed?
If we're losing all this
energy due to thermalization,
can somehow we halt it and
stop it from happening?
There are people trying.
It is a valiant fight.
This plot right here
represents what's
called the density of states.
We're going to get to that
in another lecture here,
but I'm going to expose you
to the rough concept here.
Y-axis is energy.
So again, we have our
valence band maximum
and our conduction
band minimum up there.
X-axis here is
representing time.
So we're going from the
excitation event, which
occurs right at t equals zero.
Zero plus represents what this
is on the positive side, moving
time forward from
the excitation event,
so instantaneously after
the execution event.
We had to the equilibrium
population of holes
and of electrons inside of
our semiconductor system.
There weren't absolutely
zero electrons
in the conduction
band, because of heat.
There was enough thermal
energy in our system
to excite some of
those electrons across.
And that's why we had that small
population of electrons there
and holes down here, the
holes they left behind.
Now we had a photon coming
in, high energy photon,
that excited these
electrons down here up there
into the valence band.
Up into here, in
the valence band.
And over time, this
excited population
will decay down to the
conduction band minimum
and valence band maximum,
the electrons and the holes
respectively.
And over time, when
I say over time,
I'm referring to something in
the range of one picosecond, 10
to the minus 12 seconds.
That's like that, but faster.
So we have a quick decay of
these photoexcited carriers,
and so extraction
of that energy is
going to be nearly impossible,
unless we do something
very clever with our
crystal to prevent
that decay from happening.
Somehow we suppress
the phonons from being
emitted at that frequency,
at least, or at that energy.
So there are a lot of
people, clever people,
working on this problem and
trying to prevent the decay.
The next challenge,
of course, is
extracting those so-called hot
carriers, the excited carriers,
from your device and
keeping that energy when
they're going into the metal.
That's a whole
another can of worms.
So we have the time
scales of thermalization,
and this is why, at least
from the perspective
of your homework, we're going to
treat thermalization losses as
inevitable.
As Harvard and MIT
students, I would
urge you to never consider
anything is inevitable.
If we understand the
physics well enough,
we can probably
engineer a solution.
But for now, let's consider this
a reality, a loss mechanism.
So if we start putting
things together,
if we put non absorption, which
we talked about last lecture,
we actually ran
some calculations,
back of the envelope, and
we calculated the thickness
necessary to absorb 90% of the
photons at a given wavelength.
We also know how to
calculate reflectance off
of a front surface.
And so we get this
third point right here.
We actually got it last class.
And the fourth point right here,
we intuitively understand now
that if the photon comes in with
more energy than the band gap,
that excess energy is going to
be lost due to thermalization.
So now if we have
the solar spectrum,
and we know the band
gap of a semiconductor,
we should be able to do a very
cursory plot of the efficiency
versus band gap, versus energy.
So again, we have
thermalization losses.
The band gap is too small.
And non absorption losses,
if the band gap is too large.
And let's just do an
absurd thought experiment.
If we say, OK,
I'm really, really
scared of thermalization
losses, so I'm
going to make the biggest band
gap material I possibly can,
I'm going to have a very
low efficiency in my cell,
because I'm not
absorbing any light.
The solar cell will
be transparent.
If I'm scared of
non-absorption losses,
I say, OK, I'm going to
make my band gap really,
really, really tiny.
I'm going to be losing a
heck of a lot of energy
due to thermalization,
due to this loss mechanism
right up here.
And so there has to
be some happy optimum,
somewhere between
the two, where we
have the maximum potential
efficiency of a solar cell
device, given our
solar spectrum.
We're going to walk
through that right now.
So approximating non-absorption
losses, very first step.
What we're going to do, for
our non-absorption losses,
is run a very
quick approximation
that any photon
with photon energy
corresponding to the band gap
energy is going to be absorbed.
So if our photon has a larger
energy than the band bap,
it will be absorbed.
If it has an energy
less than the band gap,
it will not be absorbed.
And that's what this plot
right here is representing.
We have wavelength right
here, longer wavelength,
lower energy.
Smaller wavelength,
larger energy.
And at some point,
we have the turn
on of absorption of
our device, because we
have band gap at that energy.
And the y-axis here,
I've plotted EQE, which
is External Quantum Efficiency.
I've coined the term over
here on the left-hand side.
It's the efficiency
at which free charge
carriers are generated by an
incident photon on the device.
So one way to think
about it is if I
have a EQE of 100%, that means
that for each photon that I
throw at my solar cell device,
I'm generating and collecting
one free carrier
from that device.
One electron hole pair, if
you will, from that device.
So that's plotted right here.
That makes intuitive sense.
This is an approximation though.
And I wanted to take it
one step further, again,
planting the flag right here.
Because we're going
to come back to this,
we're going to use this.
But I wanted to go one
level deeper into the trees,
for everyone else who wants
some more advanced concepts.
This is the reality of how
quantum efficiency looks.
Yes, we have a turn on,
depending on the material
that's involved.
We have silicon, gallium
arsenide, copper indium gallium
diselenide, amorphous silicon,
dye sensitized solar cells,
organic solar cells, a variety
of different materials right
here.
And their different turn
on wavelengths right here.
So we have wavelengths,
different energies.
Some turn on at lower energies,
others at higher energies.
So this represents, more
or less, the band gap
turn on energy, more or less.
It also has to do with
the thickness, how
it absorbs light.
At the shorter
wavelengths though,
instead of just
having a QE of one,
going all the way out
to x-ray territory,
we have a turn
off at some point.
Why is that?
Why in a real device
would we-- Yeah.
We have glass absorbing,
on the front side,
that's one real big reason.
Do we have another idea?
Yep.
Glass absorption is
one real big one.
There are other dead layers
inside of a solar cell device
in the near surface
region that also absorb
the light in some architecture.
So it's not a perfect QE
spectrum that looks like that.
But why don't we care?
For the purposes of just
engineering approximation,
why aren't we bothered
by these photons
that we're losing down there?
AUDIENCE: Because the percentage
of the solar spectrum that
falls in that region is small.
PROFESSOR: Absolutely.
So what we're doing is an
engineering approximation
right here to get to a very
first cursory efficiency
calculation, neglecting
things at the extremes.
Two short wavelengths,
because there's just not
a whole lot of solar
flux down there.
And too long wavelengths,
because again,
not a whole lot of
solar flux right there.
So we're going to be using this
approximation in our homeworks
and that will get
us somewhat close.
If we really want it to be
true, instead of using a box
function like this, an
absorption box function,
we would use an
absorption spectrum that
looks something more like that.
We've used a two
absorption spectrum.
And then convolute that with
the thickness of the device
to calculate what fraction
of photons at each energy
is absorbed inside of my device.
And that would give
you a plot that
looks something more like this.
Instead of this
box plot up here,
it might give you plot that
looks something more like this.
So you'd have instead
of just a sharp turn on,
if you had a one micron
thick silicon wafer,
and we calculated
last class that we
need somewhere around 10
microns or 100 microns
to absorb light
well, if we reduce
the thickness of the
wafer to 1/10 or 1/100
of what's necessary
to absorb light well,
we don't see that sharp
turn on at the band gap.
We see rather a gradual
turn on of our silicon
as we move to shorter and
shorter wavelengths that
are absorbed more and more
efficiently by the device.
So again, just wrapping our
head around the basic concept
that we're going to use for the
purposes of our calculation,
but, again, some of the
more fine structure,
some of the more advanced
concepts that come into
play when we're doing more
detailed calculations.
Approximating
thermalization losses now.
We want to calculate
the amount of energy
lost of incident sunlight
lost due to thermalization,
due to heat.
And we're going to say here that
if the photon energy is greater
than the band gap,
than the photon
energy is approximately the
band gap plus thermalization.
Another way to put it
would be the thermalization
is approximately
the photon energy
minus the band gap energy.
I kind of wanted to
hide all this down here.
Forget this exists right now.
Let's focus on that top part.
So that's the easy way
of thinking about it.
We're going to be
thinking about this
in terms of just
any photon coming
into our device
with a larger energy
than the band gap is going to
generate one electron hole pair
and lose some energy
due to thermalization.
The reality is that for
very high energy photons,
say for example photons with
three times the band gap energy
or more, you could have
electron-electron interactions.
So if you excite one electron
to very highly excited state,
it can bounce around and
in the process excite
another electron
across the band gap.
That's the case when x-rays are
incident on a piece of silicon.
For instance, if you have
a 10 kilo-electron volt,
so a 10,000 eV x-ray incident
on a piece of silicon,
you will generate approximately
3,000 electron hole pairs
with that one x-ray.
Because that one x-ray is
going to take an electron
and excite it to very
highly excited state,
and that's going to
excite further electrons
across the band gap as that
excited carrier decays,
as it loses it's energy and
settles at the conduction band
minimum.
So we have what's called
multiple exciton generation.
Sometimes we've heard it
as multiple free carrier
generation.
In semiconductors,
it's a hot topic,
because folks would like to
take the ultraviolet portion
of the spectrum, the high
energy, short wavelength,
portion of the solar
spectrum, and use
it to excite multiple carriers.
One photon exciting multiple
carriers across the band gap.
And so there's some
work, or was some work,
it was a hot topic for a while.
It's kind of decayed a bit.
It comes in waves.
It cycles, kind of
like a plane wave.
There is an interest, a
general interest in the field,
of how do you capture
these higher energy photons
and convert them
in some usable way,
instead of just having
thermalization loss,
instead of just having heat.
And then for really
high energy photons,
gosh, you can really get
into some neat physics.
I've given you a link
and cross section here.
This is the electron
cross section, or actually
really what it is is an
anatomic cross section,
because of the electrons in
the material versus photon
energy going through 10
eV out to 10 to eV 11.
A very high photon energy.
We're transiting from the
visible spectrum over here
deep into the infrared, and
then going into the x-ray,
and finally to the
gamma ray regime.
There you can have a number
of interesting phenomena.
You can even have an electron
hole, or electron-positron pair
generation with
gigaelectron-volt incident
radiation or above.
We're not gonna even
talk about this regime,
because the total amount of
solar flux in that regime
is really tiny
compared to visible.
But it's a lot of interesting,
fascinating physics.
So I put it on here anyway
just to keep our approximation
in focus.
So again, I'm kind of mixing
the forest in the trees
here to give you a
sense of the complexity.
But also to give you the
tools necessary to do
simple calculations.
We're going to combine this
simple approximation right here
of the non-absorption losses.
We're going to say that
any photon with energy
less than the band gap doesn't
get absorbed by our crystal.
It's gone to us.
And we're going to
make the approximation
that any photon with
energy above the band gap
will have that excess energy
loss due to thermalization.
And we put those
two things together.
And one very convenient
way of representing this
is shown in a paper in 1980.
Let me walk you through it.
So this curve right here,
this outermost curve,
represents the solar
spectrum, energy versus number
of photons.
So we have essentially
a photon density.
This is number of photons per
centimeter squared, per second.
So photon flux, if you will.
And over here we have the
energy of those photons.
And so what this is
meant to represent
is the cumulative
solar spectrum,
going from a high
energy here all the way
down to the lowest energy.
So we're essentially adding
the different components,
cumulation plot.
And if we have a photon energy
in excess of the band gap
energy, as would be the case,
say, for example three eV
photon, and let's say the band
gap is 1.35 eV, represented
by this straight
line right here,
this energy is going to be lost.
And so by drawing
this cumulation plot,
we're plotting the area here,
the energy area that is lost
to us due to thermalization.
We could also say that if
the photons have an energy
less than the band gap, that is
going to be lost to us as well.
And what we're left with is
a little box that represents
the total usable
photons, the usable
photons that we
can extract device.
This particular
plot is a little bit
complicated, because
it contains two curves.
One is this one right here.
The other one is
this one right here.
This second curve represents
another realistic loss
mechanism that we
didn't talk about yet.
And that is why the extractable
work, represented as w,
is going to be less
than the band gap energy
of our solar cell device.
So if the band gap is 1.35
eV, the total usable work
would be 0.9 eV, we'll get
to that in a lecture or two.
And that's why
the white box here
is going to be smaller than this
horizontal line box over there.
But it gives you a very first
approximation, a very easy way
to describe the different losses
that can occur in a solar cell,
and quickly visualize
them here, thermalization.
Over here, non-absorption.
And plot them out very
nicely as the total area
and representative
area fractions.
And that's why you
can see here that
the total usable
solar energy is going
to be somewhere around 30%.
This band gap right
here, around 1.35 eV
is actually pretty near
optimal for the solar spectrum.
You can imagine if we
increase the band gap energy,
we would be doing
something like this.
So we would draw another
box right around here.
This would be the new
band gap, instead of 1.35,
that would be out here.
If we increase the
band gap further,
we might have something
that looks like that.
And the area of this
little rectangle
would be much smaller than
the area of this rectangle.
Likewise, if we said, OK, we're
going to shrink our band gap
energy to avoid
non-absorption loss,
we're going to have an excess
of thermalization loss.
We'll have a very narrow
rectangle, right, like this,
and all of this would be loss.
The solar spectrum,
obviously, does not change.
This line right here this
is fixed, it's constant.
You folks kind of see it?
Beginning to grasp it?
This is a convenient way of
representing the total usable
portion of the solar spectrum
from a given semiconductor
material.
You can begin seeing the trade
offs between different material
systems.
You can say, what happens
if I change my band gap?
How would that change
the fraction of photons,
or fraction of photon
energy not absorbed?
Or fraction of photon energy
lost due to thermalization.
And you can also
see what happens
if you-- what would
be an easy way
to extract more
potential for the sun?
Instead of just using one
semiconductor material, you?
More than one.
Right.
So now you're drawing
different boxes that represent
the different materials.
And if you stack
them right, you're
able to capture more of
this total area, more
of the total solar spectrum.
So this is a really cool plot.
A lot of good work back
in the 1970s, 1980s.
If you recall from
lecture number one,
this was the first wave of
real hardcore solar science,
after the initial
Bell Labs invention.
When we had the OPEC oil crises,
and there was a large rush
of funding into solar research.
So you had a lot of good work
coming out from those days.
This next plot that
I'm going to show you
represents the area of this box
relative to the solar spectrum,
the percentage of
light that is usable,
the balance between
non-absorption thermalization
losses as a function
of band gap energy.
So if the band gap is
too small, again, we're
losing a lot of energy
due to thermalization.
If the band gap's too
large, a lot of energy
we're losing to non-absorption.
And somewhere in the
middle is our happy medium.
These little symbols here
represent different materials.
Cadmium sulfide,
cadmium telluride,
gallium arsenide, indium
phosphide, silicon, germanium,
and so forth, and
calculated efficiencies.
So I'm going to go into
one advanced concept,
the multi-junction devices.
And we just talked
about this box here
representing the usable energy
from the solar spectrum.
Now if we go to an absurd
case of 36 band gaps.
If we imagine 36 materials
with graded band gaps,
starting from large band
gap at the top to small band
gap at the back, you
can envision almost
approximating the entire curve.
And you can estimate
what the upper efficiency
limit would be with many band
gaps inside of your material.
So for one band gap,
somewhere around 37,
we'll have an entire
lecture dedicated
to calculating that number.
For two band gaps
somewhere around 50.
For three band gaps, 56.
For 36 band gaps around 72.
So you can begin seeing how
the efficiency of solar energy
conversion changes as you
change or add materials,
you move materials
to your system.
So how do you practically
do that in a real device?
Well one method is to put one
material on top of another,
much like it's
demonstrated right there.
You have E versus x.
So I have my E versus x, and
I have multiple materials.
Another way to do it would be
to use optics to split our light
into different colors.
So if we have polychromatic
or multi-colored light coming
into our system, we
somehow have a set
of optics put up that
reflect one color, or one
band of the solar
spectrum, while letting
the other portion of the
solar spectrum through it.
And we have different solar
cells with different band gaps,
each matched to
the incident light.
Each matched to the
particular color of light.
Notice this paper, 1982,
this concept was out.
So again, during that first
wave of real photovoltaics
innovation in the late
1970s and early 1980s.
And this was coming right
out of Lincoln Laboratory.
This is about 35
minutes north of here.
And this group at the time, the
group number continues to exist
and is in operation
at Lincoln Labs.
So most of the people
have moved on obviously,
but several of the ideas
continue to this day.
There was a more
recent incarnation
in 2009 of a spectral splitter,
a very similar concept
as you can see,
optics to concentrate
the light, a dichroic
mirror, meaning
it reflects certain
wavelengths, let
another portion of
the spectrum past,
and solar cell devices down
below absorbing efficiently
in that region of the spectrum
and avoiding thermalization
losses, and avoiding
non-absorption losses.
This was a $50 million
DARPA project, in fact,
involving University of Delaware
and several other companies.
And they published
the results in 2009.
It was one of their wrap
up papers that described
the results of the project.
So concepts.
To this day, this
spectral splitter it's not
in commercial production.
What is in commercial production
are the multi-junction devices,
where you stack one
on top of another.
And we'll actually be having the
benefit of using some of them
in class.
Boeing spectral lab was kind
enough to donate a set of them
for our class purposes.
Yes, question.
AUDIENCE: This is
also basically what
plants do by having
multiple different pigment
molecules in leaves, right?
That would absorb the
different wavelengths?
PROFESSOR: Well, it's not
exactly separating light
by optics in that case.
So the question was--
AUDIENCE: No, I
mean multi-junction.
PROFESSOR: Oh, the
multi-junction idea.
Yes, if you consider
that there is a reaction
process occurring in series.
The important
distinguishing feature
of the multi-junction device
is that the same current
is flowing through
the entire device.
So each sub cell has to be
current matched to the others,
because the cumulative
current output
is a harmonic mean of each one.
So in other words, you're
limited by the worst resistor
in series, if you will.
So it's very tricky
to engineer properly
these multi-junction devices.
You have to be thinking about
the current output for each sub
cell and match the currents.
That means you match the
geometry, the thickness,
but also the resistivity
of each layer and so forth.
So similar to a
plant, but not quite.
There are some special
characteristics
of the inorganic system.
So we have a small
demonstration.
I'd like to welcome Joe
up to the front as well.
We have a small demonstration
of a few of the concepts
that we've covered
today in class.
We're going to be exciting
silicon with light,
and we're going to be monitoring
the current output using
this little resistance
measurement device right here.
So actually I think it's
set to a current readout.
Yes, current readout.
So it's in microamps right now,
probably going to milliamps.
Is that right?
OK, so milliamp current readout.
Let me explain to you
what we have right here.
We have a bare piece of
silicon, and two electric leads
on either side.
So a bare piece of
silicon, no device.
Just a piece of silicon.
And we have electrical leads
coming out of either side.
We have a very low resistance
contact on either end.
For those who are
curious, we used
a mixture of indium and
gallium, soldering iron,
scratch the surface, penetrated
the native surface oxide,
and put the electrical
leads on either side.
And we have this
connected in series here
to our current readout device.
So now what we're going to do is
we're going to illuminate this.
And again, bare silicon
leads on either side,
and we're going to be
passing the current
through the current
measurement system.
Before we turn it
on, we're going
to ask people, how
many people expect
there to be current
driving through the system?
We have light incident
on the material.
We're exciting charges.
Based on today's lecture, there
should be free charges moving
around that material now.
How many expect a
current to flow?
A few.
But a lot of people
shaking their heads.
Why do you think a
current won't flow?
There's no electric field.
There's no potential.
Why don't we give it a
shot, and why don't we see.
If we turn this on right
now, what do we see?
We see zero.
Right.
Can some of the folks right
here in the front see?
Says zero.
All right, so what this
is telling us again,
you're welcome to come up after
class and take a closer look.
What this is telling us here is
that yes, what we talked about
in class is important today.
Yes, it's all very
important and it's
the foundation of calculating
ultimate solar cell
efficiency, how the material
absorbs the light, how
charge is excited.
But we need something else too.
Once the charge is
excited, somehow we
have to give it an incentive
to leave the material.
We have to have a field.
In this case, we're going to
be using an applied field,
a couple of batteries.
So total voltage around
three volts, applied
across that small material.
But in a solar
cell device, we're
going to have a built
in electric field
that we'll engineer
into the device.
And we'll talk about
that over next lecture.
So just for purposes of sanity,
we have our batteries now
connected in series, and
is now applying a potential
across those two leads.
And now if we turn on the
light, what do we expect?
We expect to see some
current going through.
And voila, we have a
current running through it.
So now, what is the
nature of that current?
If we move the light closer,
we see the number go up.
What is the nature
of that current?
That current is photo excited.
That current is
exciting electrons
from the valence band,
from bound states,
into the conduction band,
it's unbound states,
where they can move freely
across the material.
And now, because we have
that potential applied
across the material, there's
an incentive for them
to drift in one direction.
The net flow of electrons
is in one direction.
We have a drift current in our
material, in our semiconductor,
and hence we have
the flow of charge
that is readable by this
current meter right here.
So without the light,
we have no current.
With the light, we have current
flowing through the material.
But current and
light-- actually light
is not the only thing necessary
to create that output current.
We also need the potential.
So next class we'll be
talking about the potential
and how that's created inside
of a solar cell device.
I've included a few slides
extra for people to see through.
I'm going to explain once
again the experiment.
We just had light coming in.
It was in the visible.
We were able to excite
carriers, but no current
was observe because we
didn't have a potential.
When we applied the battery,
or the potential across, now
when we shone light
of the sample,
we had a current
flowing through.
And we even have a
current, a very small one,
flowing through when we
have the battery applied
without the light on.
And you need microamp detection
I think to really see it.
Yeah.
Just from the battery.
These are a very small
population of excited carriers,
either thermally or donated to
the electron conduction band.
Any questions before
we close for the day?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, so I guess--
I'm the devices person in here,
so also the notion of
the direct band gap,
versus an indirect band gap,
are we going to discuss that?
Or is that something
that's not relevant?
PROFESSOR: We will
definitely discuss
direct and indirect band gaps.
So this goes back to
describing the notion
of a direct and an
indirect band gap
is fundamental for
describing the reason
why these curves have
the shape they do.
For example, this
one right here,
if you plotted as alpha-- if
you plot it in a certain way,
you'll be able to see a
very characteristic shape,
indicative of direct transition
into a direct band gap.
The reason we aren't launching
into several of those terms
right now is because
several of your colleagues,
more than half, don't have
a semiconductor physics
background.
And the beauty of
this approach is
that you will be
able to understand
most things about a solar cell
without really diving deep
into the semiconductor
physics until it's necessary.
And hopefully we keep
everybody with us.
So for those who have a
strong semiconductor physics
background, I bid you, I
urge you to have patience,
because we will get to
the interesting stuff.
But we're working on that
fundamental background
right now.
Thanks.